[Music]
hi everyone is Charlie HBO released
another preview for Game of Thrones
season 8 so we'll break it down there's
just a whole bunch of stuff the actors
have also said a couple things about
what's going on with their characters so
I'll just work that in as we work our
way down this list we've only got a
couple weeks to go before the season
starts so be sure to subscribe if you're
just finding me for the first time or if
you're coming back for Game of Thrones
I'll be doing videos all season long I
do weekly book giveaways all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so starting
with number 10 this scene seems like
it's the same one that we see during the
trailer seriously outside the read keep
watching you're on ships come in with a
golden company this really seems like an
episode one scene because the only
teasers that we got for her storyline
during season 8 at the end of season 7
we're reminding Jamie that she was
pregnant she referred to the baby as the
one yet to come because she doesn't know
whether it's a boy or a girl or a
hideously deformed dwarf for all you
truthers out there they usually start
each character's scenes at the beginning
of each season addressing where they
left off so the smug look on her face
just seems like she's supremely
confident that all that gold from the
iron bank that she spent on the golden
company is gonna pay off remember she's
back to zero with the iron bank because
she spent all that tire gold to repay
the iron Thrones debt to the iron bank
lump-sum that's why he was so surprising
maybe there's something else that we can
help you with maybe there's another loan
we can give you that's where she got all
the money for the golden company so as
of the beginning of season 8 the Iron
Throne is back in debt to the iron bank
I only ventured this moment is
reestablishing control over this
continent and every person on it I see a
great deal of potential in that venture
I imagined it would require outside
investment it will indeed I need to
expand my armies my navies my hand
Qyburn has made overtures to the golden
company in Essos so Lena Headey was
talking about Circe's storyline and says
that she feels kind of trapped during
season 8 but she's putting on a brave
face part of the box that she sort of
builds herself into is being in debt to
the iron bank again remember that's
always been a really big problem for the
Iron Throne going all the way back to
Robert Baratheon even at the beginning
of this season part of Littlefinger
scheme to destabilize the realm and just
create chaos which is continued to find
ways for Robert to work then
burr in deeper into debt moving on
number nine this is Sansa meeting
Johnston with Daenerys look at Brienne
and pod behind her she's putting on her
best resting [ __ ]
this is maester wolkan standing right
next to her and you can actually see
bran sitting in his wheelchair if you
look way down at the bottom of frame but
it kind of cuts him off at the head this
is a much better picture of him in the
yard so it's hard to tell when this one
is happening because it doesn't seem
like it's the same scene but this
picture just confirms that he'll be
there when everyone's meeting today's
for the first time in the courtyard
number eight this is brand inside his
room that you saw him in at the end of
season seven with Samwell you can't tell
who he's talking to here but he's just
talking to one or more of them Samwell
seems like he's gonna be spending the
most amount of time with him during the
season seven this is Tyrion just outside
the castle walls inspecting all the
preparations in the middle of the day so
this is either happening after their
meeting during episode one or sometime
during episode two some of these images
do seem like they're happening during
episode two you see all the barriers
that they're erecting just to slow down
the hordes of white so that takes them
longer to try and get over the walls
the whites can't use catapults they
can't use battering rams as far as we
know to beat down the front gates so the
White Walkers would have to use their
undead giant for that if you remember we
got a vision of it way back during
season seven episode one that was brands
vision of the army coming
the whites could just pile on top of
each other one at a time forming a
makeshift mount to climb over each other
to then get over the walls much less
elegant solution for the White Walkers
but very effective nonetheless that's
why you see them fighting whites on the
battlements up on top of the castle
walls because they've slowly started to
get over as far as we know they're about
a hundred thousand strong the last time
Jon Snow was talking about him but I
wouldn't be surprised if the army gets a
little bit bigger as the White Walkers
slowly pick up strays as they wind their
way down to Winterfell six this is
Daenerys and one of her new northern
design inspired dresses sitting at the
head of the table at the Great Hall
Winterfell looking none too pleased with
whatever their current argument is
probably something to do with battle
planning pretty safe bet that the
northern Lords will not rush to welcome
her to their presence so I expect it to
be pretty cold the first couple of
meetings that they have in there this is
just a wider version of that shot so you
can actually see a little bit more of
the frame but you can't see who's
sitting right next to her depending on
how much room you think is at that table
it's a pretty big table it would still
be Jon Snow Sansa and Brants
there with her this is her in the same
dress but from a different scene inside
that Great Hall probably from the same
episode the look on her face just makes
it seem like she's worried about
something or she just got some
distressing news but she's having a much
smaller meeting with one or two of the
other characters five the shot of Tyrion
is also in the Great Hall but because
all the tables around him are empty and
the candles are all burned down it seems
like it's after one of the meetings that
they have and he's having a more private
discussion about what just transpired
either with Daenerys or Jon Snow or a
couple other people for this is Daenerys
and Sir Jorah still wearing the same
outfits that they had when they first
arrived at Winterfell he's still baring
his armor she's still wearing that
original white dress that she had way
back during season seven so it seems
like it's happening earlier in the
episode before their big costume changed
the room that they're in has all these
bookshelves and Scrolls behind them so
maybe they're talking to Jon Samwell and
bran
but it just seems like their version of
Daenerys map table room a place for all
the leaders to actually meet with each
other before you have a giant meeting in
the Great Hall with all the northern
Lords three this is Daenerys in the same
room you can see all the books behind
her on that same shelf but she's got on
her new northern inspired outfit and
she's sitting at the table smiling at
whoever she's talking to like she's
really happy to meet someone so maybe
this is later in the episode when she is
talking to someone like Samwell and
whatever this library room is trying to
explain something to her fumbling all
over his words Brant
only gives cryptic statements and
disturbing portents of what's to come so
when someone is talking to brand usually
the look on their face is one of horror
or extreme surprise
Hodor in summer dyed fee I almost died
for you
I'll tell you more so if anyone is gonna
make Daenerys smile like this it's
probably gonna be Samwell because I
wouldn't expect Arya to rush to welcome
her either and obviously Sansa early in
the episode is gonna be pretty cold to
her as well I think it's pretty
reasonable to assume that Daenerys is
gonna spend most of these first couple
of episodes trying to win over the
people of Winterfell particularly the
she-wolves of Winterfell mostly Sansa
Arya Stark and then of course the
northern Lords but she probably wouldn't
try to be quite so charming with them
like you see her at the head of the
great table it seems like she'll be
approaching them for more of a position
of strength like they'll see her might
and see all the things that she's done
and see that Jon Snow factors for her
through her actions she'll slowly win
them over but when it comes to winning
family members over like Sansa Stark
Arya Stark because she cares about Jon
Snow so much and even if they don't
address it directly in the first couple
of episodes if they were to ever get
married they would literally be family
so it's pretty reasonable to assume that
she would try to bend over backwards to
win them over if you had a chance to
read George RR Martin's fire and blood
there was also Alison Targaryen the
Queen at the time who was wife to Jo
Harris the first who visited Winterfell
the Lord at the time was Alaric Stark
they absolutely hated her when she
arrived with her dragon she slowly won
them over and they were much closer by
the time that she left to go north to
the wall to inspect the Nights Watch so
it's a relatively similar situation with
Daenerys during season 8 - this is
Brienne out in the courtyard just
watching the preparations for the battle
this shot those of her inside maybe
inside the Great Hall during one of
their meetings because you still wearing
the coat over her armor all this seems
like it's happening relatively early in
the episodes the actress Gwendoline
Christie said that we see more of
Brienne during season eight than we've
ever seen of her before which makes
sense you sort of get this proximity
effect because everybody's there
together so you don't to skip an episode
with a bunch of characters because
they're off in some other part of
Westeros that's not really critical to
what's ever happening in the moment with
very few exceptions all the main
characters on the show are gonna be in
one of two places either up at
Winterfell or down in King's Landing I
think Jamie is gonna be a bit of a
straggler working his way up to
Winterfell and then Melisandre is still
over in the east there are a couple
pictures of the characters outside at
night number one this picture of Sansa
holding the cup of what seems like super
maybe something she's drinking might
just be her inspecting all the
preparations for the battle she's
small smile on her face so whatever's
happening in this scene here it seems
like she's chilled out a little bit this
picture of John snow also seems like
he's outside in the courtyard in the
middle of night somewhere between
Episode one and Episode two while
they're preparing for everything and
even though they haven't released an
official clip of it yet they said that
they gave the opening credits a big
upgrade like they do every season they
just changed things a little bit so
Winterfell will look a little bit
different King's Landing will look
different maybe they'll finally add the
lion sigil over King's Landing and maybe
you'll see some dragon or a Targaryen
sigil up at Winterfell
but they did say that the upgrades were
meant to reflect the different things
that are happening in those places at
the beginning of the season because
we're only two weeks away from the show
getting here they're gonna be a couple
more bonus videos that I'll do between
now and then they'll probably drop a
couple more promos I'm not expecting a
ton of brand-new footage but we might
get something in the next couple of days
leave all your video requests in the
comments below I've already got a couple
big videos planned but if there's
anything specifically that you want me
to address in a video just let me know
in the comments
congratulations Dante 74 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my breakdown
of that last big season 8 episode 1
preview that they've released a little
while ago and click here for all my
Easter eggs from the season 8 trailer
that implied Jon Snow will be riding
dragons during season 8 thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight